this is not a drill people love the
internet restaurant tour here and
according to two official job postings
from Avalanche software the developers
behind Hogwarts Legacy work on an
unannounced AAA console title is
underway or at least it's about to begin
very soon we have to break this down
right here right now could it be
Hogwarts like a C2 is it just DLC I
don't think so you'll see why here in a
moment first though let's take a look at
the exact quotes for each of these
listings okay so here's the first one
and it's for a software engineer located
in Salt Lake City Utah and it is for a
full-time position there's a lot of
stuff in here relating to avalanche's
history benefits some legal info but
here are the juicy bits if you're a
Hogwarts Legacy fan there's a section
that says what part will you play so for
this position you will develop gameplay
systems develop and maintain tools for
production of AAA game titles
collaborate with other engineers and
clients to develop maintain debug and
ship games and the last one write and
review code develop documentation and
debug problems on on game systems now I
know what you guys are thinking retro
that doesn't say anything about a new
title or anything about an unannounced
title but wait there's more remember how
I said there's a lot of stuff at the
beginning relating to avalanche's
history well tucked away in that fourth
paragraph is an ever so important line
that says Avalanche software a division
of Warner Brothers games Incorporated
seeks a software engineer to join our
talented team working on an unannounced
AAA console title boom There It Is Write
in their own words okay now to the other
job listing this one is for an associate
software engineer and it is also for a
full-time position a few slight
differences though when it comes to what
part will you play you'll design and
write production game code and
blueprints create tools and processes
used in production work with designers
to implement and tune various in-game
scenarios document implemented features
systems and new approaches and lastly
work with engineering team and QA to
identify issues and fix them that same
line though about the unannounced AAA
console title it's also present here in
this one and the fact that it appears in
two different job postings I think
eliminates the possibility of this being
maybe some sort of mistake or typo I
mean if they copy paste it over from one
listing to the next maybe but again that
very sentence mentioning the unannounced
AAA console title it also mentions the
specific job so basically it changes in
each one to match the job now to be
totally fair if we're talking about the
chances of a typo we also have to
consider that there are some incorrect
bits of information in the previous
paragraph because it says something
about how they're currently working on
Hogwarts Legacy and the game is set for
release in 2022 even though of course we
know it's 2023 and the game is already
out at least on current gin but I have
double and triple checked it is an
active listing this is not an old
listing unless it's an error on their
part which we'll continue to watch and
monitor this to see if anything changes
my next question though and the one I
know you guys are all asking what could
this be for so let's walk through some
of the possibilities here could this be
for a Hogwarts Legacy DLC if you
remember shortly after the game's launch
on current gen game director Alan 2 told
IGN there were no current plans for DLC
basically they were focused on getting
the game out for PS4 and Xbox One Gamers
well guess what folks this is the week
of May 5th launch week for those on PS4
and Xbox One so two things here I don't
know if this specifically is referring
to the DLC but at the same time I also
think a DLC almost has to happen I mean
it has to right a game cannot do this
well and then not get any post launch
support I still fully believe there will
be a DLC at some point it's just a
matter of when not if but as it relates
to this specific story there's just
something about that unannounced AAA
console title to me that doesn't sound
like a DLC now maybe this is how some
studios refer to DLC maybe they consider
an expansion as an unannounced title I
could possibly see that if you think
about things like The Witcher when they
released blood and wine it was almost
like its own separate thing so maybe
blood and wine was considered an
unannounced title at some point I don't
know I still lean more toward less
likely but I do think there's a chance
the other possibility and I think a
pretty strong possibility is that work
on a Hogwarts legacy sequel is now
underway you guys want to see a sequel
right hit that like button to let me
know if you guys want to see a Hogwarts
Legacy too of course this would be years
away but definitely not as long as
Hogwarts Legacy considering they already
have so many of the tools and systems up
and running so let's do a little math
here work on Hogwarts Legacy began
around 2017 we don't know for sure
exactly when it began but somewhere
around there and then the game released
in early 2023 so that's roughly a five
to six year development time so my best
guess I could potentially see a Hogwarts
Legacy 2 as early as maybe late 2026
early 2027 and that's especially if this
hiring that we're seeing right here is
in fact related to Hogwarts Legacy 2. I
guess there is another possibility one I
don't really want to think about but
there is a chance this could be
something completely unrelated to
Hogwarts and unrelated to The Wizarding
World I think chances for that are
incredibly low given how much passion
and how much excitement we saw that the
dev team had for this project Alan two
even talked early on about how they
wanted to do more in this world with our
help which of course meant if the game
sold well and guess what it absolutely
has we are still waiting on the full
updated numbers which I think we could
be getting those very soon either at an
upcoming WB stockholder meeting or a
week or two after the launch of last gen
I mean the game just absolutely
shattered even wb's expectations it sold
256 percent more than expected earned
more than 850 million in the first two
weeks on the market and I have a full
breakdown for all those sales numbers
that we have so far in the next video
you can check it out on the right side
of your screen and of course sound off
in the comments to let me know what you
guys think about this news is that a DLC
is it a sequel something different
either way I can't wait to see what's in
store next for Avalanche software as
always guys thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon